This program is being presented to you
by the Heraeus International Winter
School on gravity and light.
So, welcome to the actually last central
lecture of the winter school.
Um today we'll wrap up
uh
these central lectures and I will
actually
uh explain something I didn't explain to
you, namely why the Einstein action has
the form it has.
So, we uh took great care to explain how
the entire structure of the theory
uh is founded from set theory over
topology and so on. But uh actually the
Einstein action and hence the Einstein
equations uh were just presented.
And in fact, that's uh
one simple textbook view that one can
take and that's often taken that the
gravitational dynamics are postulated
alongside the matter dynamics that are
postulated as well and you postulate
them such that the result describes
nature.
And that's absolutely fine, that's
absolutely correct.
However, if you postulate several
things, you got to make sure that you
don't postulate two things that are
contradictory.
And if indeed one can be derived from
the other or one is greatly constrained
by the other postulate,
then we should know.
In order to first understand the theory
better, second in order to be sure that
there are no contradictions, and third
because such understanding usually
points beyond what we already know in a
concrete context, it yields a deeper
understanding.
So, what I would like uh to report about
today is uh the work by a whole number
of people
and um the it can be summarized at uh
answering the question how quantizable
matter gravitates.
Now, I don't know how many of you had a
course on quantum theory
in the universities. Okay. So, you all
know that there's this issue of you have
a matter theory
uh and you want to quantize it in order
to get the corresponding quantum theory.
And it's a very complicated question how
to quantize and whether that is a
well-defined procedure in the first
place and so on.
So, if here we speak about quantizable
matter, it's not quantum matter, it's
quantizable matter. We speak of the
classical description of matter, no
doubt about that. But it should be a
classi- classical description of matter
that can be quantized.
Now, uh at least it needs to satisfy
some necessary conditions for
quantization because otherwise we would
ultimately not consider it as a good
matter model today because we we require
that all matter be quantizable.
Now, it will turn out
that if you start with a quantizable
matter model like for instance Maxwell
theory, electromagnetic waves,
or well, the whole theory, that the
theory already carries in itself the
information of how it gravitates.
In other words, it carries in it the
information that gravity should look
like Einstein gravity.
Um I will explain this and I will
explain in a general context uh that
will also include other matter that
could produce other gravity theories.
So, that's the idea of uh these final
lectures today.
And um so, let me introduce you here and
today it will be less of a lecture style
like usually that you have lots of
indices to follow, today it's about the
ideas behind all of that. Of course,
there will be some technical detail, but
you're well prepared.
So, I would like to explain why gravity
can be derived from given matter
dynamics and need not be postulated. And
of course, uh that makes a big
difference that it can be derived from
given matter dynamics. It has a massive
impact
on our thinking about gravity simply
because if ever we have to consider
different matter in the universe because
it's discovered, we will maybe, and the
talk will show you under which
circumstances, have to consider
different gravity theory.
But the best thing it it will be
constructive. So, if there's new matter,
we know exactly what to do, how to get
the new gravity.
So, let me start with the standard model
of fundamental physics that includes
gravity and matter and in fact, in this
school you were already quite well
educated in that. So, if you want to
start doing physics and you talk about
space and time on which you want to put
matter and we're not questioning uh this
division, uh then you start with some
sets, then you may get the idea that you
need some topology on there if you want
to do classical physics, that you want a
smooth atlas and so on. And then you
know,
at some point, if you have enough
structure, namely a smooth manifold,
then you can start thinking about
tensors and tensor fields.
And tensor fields are at this stage of
development the only matter you can put
on a manifold, on a smooth manifold.
Spinners, who have no you know what
knows what a spinner is?
Spin one half and so on. Spinners cannot
be put on the manifold at this stage,
but soon they will be. So, um you can
put tensor fields. So, vector fields,
covector fields and so on.
So, now this is the uh conceptual
foundation that you need to start with
before you can start talking about the
standard model of fundamental physics as
we have it today.
But now I would like to jump back to
1850 or 1860 when uh Maxwell formulated
his Maxwell equations. I don't think you
can read this very well. So, here it
says uh we look at observations. So, for
instance, there was the observation that
currents induce magnetic fields.
That's uh Ampere or something. And mov-
pardon me?
And and mov- and moving magnets induce
currents. Those were Ampere's or
Faraday's law and Maxwell combined them
into the Maxwell equations and uh he
added a little term and so on. But from
a modern point of view, what he did, he
built on the building as it is presented
here and he wrote down his Maxwell
theory of electromagnetism.
Of course, Maxwell didn't think of
tensors really and smooth atlases and
topologies and sets not at all, okay?
But from a modern perspective, that is
what he did. So, that is where we are
here 1850, 1860, around that.
Well, then the story, you know how it
continued in 1905, probably earlier, uh
Einstein stared at the Maxwell
equations.
And he realized that if these equations
are true, and they ought to be true
because they describe all kinds of
phenomena that were known at the time,
he saw after all, that took a few years
and the help of others, Minkowski and
others, to realize actually on this the
space has a structure all by itself. It
it carries a geometric structure, which
today we call a Lorentzian metric.
Well, they thought of it first of a flat
Lorentzian metric because that was the
first thing you think about, but after
all, the decisive observation was that
something, some theory that came from
observations,
dictated that you think of space-time
this way. So, this is the famous 1905
insight by Einstein. He didn't call it
Lorentzian metric, he wrote down rather
cumbersome equations, but if you really
analyze it from there, it was actually
just a logical conclusion.
Now, later, and that's now uh
100 years ago or 99 years and uh 11
months or something, um Einstein
realized that this Lorentzian metric
better also be given some dynamics
because after all, the metric
coefficients feature in the Maxwell
equations that you all saw, the Maxwell
action is coefficients, but where do
these coefficients come from? You can
brutally set them to zero,
but you can also give them some
dynamics. And what comes out is the
dynamics of the background on which the
theory lives, on which the waves for
instance propagate. But if the
background changes, then the waves
propagate differently and the
propagation and the dynamics of this
background was chosen such it captures
the gravitational effects. So, how for
instance waves gravitate. Today we know
the Einstein equations, they relate the
energy uh the Einstein curvature of
space-time to the energy momentum tensor
of the matter and thereby they encode
how the gra- matter gravitates with
itself, with other stuff and so on. So,
this is we started 1850, 1905, 1915, we
arrived here. That's the picture.
Now,
there is one further ingredient to the
story and the further ingredient is
spinorial matter. Actually, that
shouldn't have vanished yet, but okay.
Um so, if you have a Lorentzian metric,
only then can you start talking about
spin- you know, spinners or fermions on
space-time. And in fact, the famous spin
one half is not a quantum mechanical
thing, it's a thing, a concept that
comes out of the representation theory
of the isometry group of a flat
Lorentzian metric, the so-called
Poincaré group. It's a geometric thing,
the spin. And in fact, once you have a
Lorentzian metric, you can, under
certain circumstances, there are some uh
obstructions, but uh
you can impose spinners on a manifold.
So, really the spinners come after
Lorentzian metric. Without Lorentzian
metric, you don't have spinners. Okay,
so that there's a logical
uh thing here going on.
And now you have tensorial matter and
spinorial matter, and you can choose
what in nature you want or you need to
describe uh by which. And it turns out
that the spinorial matter is always
fermions, so they have they satisfy
fermionic statistics. You know that
probably from uh statistical mechanics,
and the tensorial matter encodes bosons.
Now, if you take the two together, we
started here in 1850 with Maxwell's
theory that was the kickstart.
Everything that comes after Lorentzian
metric actually is based on what
Einstein read in the Maxwell equations.
But then you see you can have other
matter and so on. So, you take the
Maxwell equations extremely seriously,
and the courageous step by Einstein was
that the Maxwell equations are to be
taken so seriously
that what follows from them is the
foundation of all of physics.
He was very lucky that that is true. It
could have been that the Maxwell
equations only capture a little bit, and
there's much more out there.
But in fact, he did that, and then today
we formulate all matter in terms of the
standard model of particle physics in
terms of tensorial and spinorial matter,
where the spinorial matter firmly rests
on the concept of Lorentzian metric.
So, all of this fits nicely together,
and uh constitutes what today we call
the standard model of fundamental
physics, the standard model of gravity,
with the standard model of particle
physics, and that is what any textbook
wants to convey to you, and is of course
correct. It's an extremely successful
theory. It's been extremely successful
for for a very long time. That's the
standard model, and it's a little bit
the logical path we followed in this
course, apart from the spinorial matter,
which we didn't do.
Now, if we confront that with
experiment, you already know we
calculated that in the cosmology
uh course, and you also heard it in
Valeria Pettorino's lectures, uh we have
a fact that the standard model matter
that we so proudly describe by the
standard model only constitutes about 5%
of the matter and energy in the
universe. So, those are
observations that now for uh about 20
years uh are more and more corroborated.
So, if you apply the model I showed to
you before,
and you evaluate the raw data with that,
you come to this conclusion.
We know that. So, that means that here
the standard model dynamics, which here
in this nice textbook picture thrown up
here at the same level with Einstein
gravity dynamics, and both have to be
postulated and modeled to work together,
and everything is fine. Well, in fact,
you have here 95% dark stuff. I call it
disrespectfully dark stuff because we
don't really know where that comes from.
Okay? Um and it's uh well, the dark
that's why it's called stuff. The dark
thing is of course because it only
interacts gravitationally. It couples to
this background metric, one assumes,
okay? And um uh but it doesn't couple to
any of the other standard model matter
in here.
So, most of what is out there is not of
standard model type.
And by my argument, what is standard
model type is actually Maxwell type,
right? You start with Maxwell, you come
to there, and you bootstrap the whole
standard model of particle physics
because you say all the matter has been
created in the image of Maxwell theory,
right?
And now we have this situation, and one
logical possibility is that all that
dark stuff uh somebody will come, will
write it down in standard model style,
the standard model will be extended in a
very conservative way, um that would be
actually preferable, of course, uh and
after all, the whole picture stays as it
is.
Just we do not know. We simply do not
know,
and um so, if we take that seriously
that we don't know, and that's the right
thing to do,
then we have to delete everything I
deleted now in the current textbook
picture because if the matter works
fundamentally different from Maxwell and
hence other standard model matter, then
all the conclusions we drew from it are
to be questioned.
Of course, you can always question more.
You can question whether you should have
a smooth manifold. You could question
whether you should have a topology at
all. You should question Okay.
The game here is we only question what
we are prompted to question, but what
we're prompted to question, we take
seriously. So, you have to delete that.
So, it's virtually all I taught you.
Now,
the point is what we should do, we
should redo the whole thing.
We should start with any matter, any new
matter, any matter, not only Maxwell
matter.
But then, what do you mean by any what
do I mean by any matter? You can't make
write down theorems for any matter.
There is not enough structure. So, we
need to make assumptions about the
matter we expect to be out there, even
if it's dark matter or dark energy,
okay, or any yet to be discovered
matter.
And um well, so if we now make
assumptions, we can of course follow our
taste. We can say, "Well, let's make an
assumption. I like strings. Okay, let's
use strings." Or I like this, or I have
this I always had this idea that physics
should be done with purely complex
numbers, right? You can have ideas like
this, but again, I would
rather go for some very conservative
approach. I would say, "Let's only
require of matter what we all agree on
must be required."
And um
that is probably on the one hand
predictivity. So, if we are still
talking about classical matter theories,
they should be predictive. If you come
up with a new matter theory, say
tomorrow you write down a theory for
dark matter,
and it's not predictive in the sense of
that initial conditions are translated
into later values of the field, it would
be rejected outright by the physics
community, justifiedly, because physics
is about predicting the future.
So, certainly we want matter a matter
model that's predictive.
But the other really important input in
what we learned in 20th century physics
is that all matter is quantum.
Well, at least so we believe.
So, if we make a classical matter model
to fit it into here, it should at least
be quantizable.
You it should not
uh obstruct quantization.
If we make these two assumptions, and I
will tell you how to make them
technically,
one can show, and I will illustrate this
in this lecture, that that already gives
rise uniquely to new tensorial geometry.
So, not the tensorial geometry described
by a metric, by Lorentzian metric, but
possibly by all other kinds of tensors,
but just not any tensor. Like a
Riemannian metric would not do.
But a Lorentzian does, and many others.
I'll explain that.
Now, of course, we're here kind of in
1905 if we repeat the history here. Now,
what if we want to give this new
tensorial geometry, which provides the
coefficients of the matter equations, if
you and we must provide dynamics for
that. Um oh, well, they can have
non-tensorial matter, and then you can
provide dynamics, and indeed you get new
gravitational dynamics.
And if I have these arrows here, they
don't mean, "Well, you should and one
could." Uh they mean we know how to do
that. And I'll explain it.
Okay. Uh
by the same token, of course, if you
start here with Maxwell,
what you need to do, you can now follow
this in a modern way, and you arrive at
Einstein gravity again. So, at the same
time as it provides the path to new
gravitational theories starting from new
matter, which you need to observe and
formulate in equations, it provides you
with a clean-cut explanation why if you
start with Maxwell theory on the one
side, that you need to end up with
Einstein gravity on the other side.
Okay? So, it's also an explanation of
what we already have.
So, this is uh the picture I want to
convey. So, the central result of today,
I'll announce it in the beginning, is
you start and you give me some
predictive and quantizable matter
equations in form of an action. So,
you're an observer, you watch out there,
you see what not the bullet cluster, and
you come up with a very bright idea of
how to formulate
what's going on there as a matter model.
Okay? As a local matter model, and you
come and you say, "These are the
equations for dark matter. We checked it
here, here, here. What we see there
locally, that is how it works."
And then you say, "However, there is a
problem. This is my matter field, but
unfortunately, I need coefficients it
couples to that do not look like the
coefficients of a Lorentzian metric."
Well, maybe they do, then everything is
fine. But say you need coefficients
that are different from a Lorentzian
metric. And one possibility, for
instance, would be the following. If you
observed tomorrow
It's unlikely that you observe it
directly, but to illustrate the point.
If you tomorrow you observe that there
is a light ray out there in vacuum,
and all of a sudden, it splits into two.
If you observe that,
then general relativity, with its
Lorentzian metric, is dead.
the same moment.
We know such splitting of light rays
from the laboratory.
If you have a birefringent crystal
and you send a light ray,
it will split into its polarization
components. Have you seen that?
I'm sorry.
It will split into its polarization
components. In fact, while the vacuum is
described by such a metric, such a
linear medium is described by a fourth
rank tensor.
Okay? So, one can show that. You trust
me. So, that means if you observe the
same thing in the sky, then you need to
write down a modified Maxwell theory
with such a structure.
Okay? So, it's not like pure fantasy.
One can very clearly write down
phenomena that immediately mean the
death of general relativity. So, assume
nevertheless you see this and you write
down the new equations, then I claim
from these equations, from this action,
you can construct a linear homogeneous
system of partial differential
equations, a linear system.
Uh it has the slight disadvantage that
it has infinitely many equations, but
that doesn't shock us.
I tell you we know how to do that. The
straightforward algorithm, no brain
power required, you convert that into
such a system. It's not the equations of
motion for this. It's it's a complicated
way you get the system, and once you
have it,
you solve it. Well, that's a little bit
more tricky.
But once you solve that system, and I'll
talk about the system. All I tell you
about today is how to get the system of
PDEs and how you extract it from the
matter equations. Once you have it, you
solve it, and the solution is the
Lagrangian of gravity
that is required
in order to be the background for this
theory such that the theory is both
predictive and quantizable.
And that you need.
That's the idea.
And um
the familiar example is you put in the
standard model action.
So, all the the electrons and Maxwell
and
uh
electroweak force and everything, or
just Maxwell's also good. You get a
linear homogeneous PDE systems, as I
said, a particular one with particular
coefficients. You solve it, and hooray,
the Einstein action I introduced to you
with undetermined gravitational
constant, undetermined
um
cosmological constant, which appear as
integration constants when you solve
this,
is the solution.
This would then be the reason, once I
explain to you how this works. This is
just the the announcement of this
result.
This is then explanation for the
Einstein theory in if our matter is the
standard model matter. Okay? So, you
don't need to postulate that separately.
It's actually derivable.
All right. And of course, the general
principle is that you will look out
there, not put in the standard model,
but you put in what you really see.
Well, that's a complicated business. You
need to write down equations for that
and so on. You put that in, and you get
the relevant gravity theory.
Now, you say, "What if we see the
standard model and other stuff?" Well,
that's then in total it's a new matter
theory, and you get the relevant gravity
theory, possibly a modification of
general relativity.
So, let me explain
to you in two steps of how this works.
The first step, you need to understand
the new matter, and you need to
understand the space-time structure that
follows from it. If I say new matter, it
could be the old matter, then you will
just have as a result the old space-time
structure.
And the key to all of this is something
called the principal polynomial of the
matter field equations. Whenever you
have field equations, like Maxwell's
equations, they're partial differential
equations, and they can come from an
action. Now, if you vary the action with
respect to the matter field, which I
just denote by a phi here, you will
invariably
arrive at a partial differential
equation for the matter field. So, there
are many derivatives acting on the
matter field, and it will have
coefficients. Well, the coefficients
could depend on the matter field as
well, because it needn't be linear
matter field equations, but it will
always look something like this.
Now, one question people always ask is
"Don't I have to use covariant
derivatives here?" Because if this is
already a tensor field, you need to use
covariant derivatives. Or even if it's a
scalar field, from the second derivative
onwards, you need covariant derivatives.
Well, these are partial derivatives, but
they have coefficients, and there's a
sum of many.
And if you think about this, the lower
coefficients, they can provide, for
instance, what we call the gamma
symbols.
But maybe in a more complicated
geometry,
uh not coming from a metric, maybe you
have to generalize the idea of a
connection, too.
We know examples for that. And I don't
want to assume any of that. You can't uh
start by saying, "Oh, maybe if we knew
the geometry, then we could do
something." But we don't. The point is
to find out about the geometry. It's not
to already know it. So, you start from
some matter action that you observe, you
write this down, and you have these
coefficients, and um
anything is fine, because it comes from
a matter action. This is fully
covariant. The coefficients carry all
the non-triviality.
Now, the great thing that mathematicians
found out is if you want to understand
the causality of these equations, so how
can signals run, where do I need to put
my initial conditions, which is very
important for physicists, you don't need
to study the whole equation, you only
look at the highest order coefficient.
So, if this goes up to the nth
derivative, you look at the coefficient
Q A1 to A capital N, the highest order
coefficient. It's the only one that's
relevant. Yes. Um
do you not allow for zeroth order?
Uh I do, and this is a mistake that that
keeps in my slides to check the
attention of the audience. Uh so,
indeed, this should start from zero.
Thank you very much. Yeah. Okay. No,
it's really true. I mean, as every talk,
I I forget to to correct that. It starts
from zero. There can be a constant.
So, you look at the high Yes.
So, if
A runs from zero to
to three.
A, no. A is an index. A1 to AN is the
first the zero A A0 to AN is the zeroth
index to the nth index. No, it's not
true. No, no. A runs from one to N,
because if N is zero, then there no
derivatives, but there is still the
field itself.
It's not so important. So, the point is
it should read like um
Q
phi plus Q A1 del A1 phi plus Q A1
A2 del A1 del A2 phi and so on.
A it's A1 itself
Oh, over the dimensions of the manifold.
I'm sorry. Okay, so I understood this
understood so on a smooth manifold of
dimension D, so this runs over the
dimension over what else on the partial
derivative? Dimension dimension of the
manifold. Okay. So, you look You only,
if you want to understand the causal
structure, you only look at the highest
order coefficient.
What do you do with that? Well, the
highest order coefficient, you can plug
in
a covector K, which has an index A1, but
you can plug it in several times such as
to fill all these indices. So, you make
a full contraction, the same covector
again and again.
What do you get? Well, you get a
polynomial, right?
Now, um
if this field here phi is a tensor
field, it carries some
indices, then the Q carries double the
number of indices, because they need to
connect to this and from the variation
gets these indices, and you need to get
rid of these indices, and the
mathematicians instruct us to take the
determinant over these indices.
To achieve what? To construct overall a
polynomial
at each point of the underlying
manifold,
and the polynomial is in the K. So, it's
a polynomial in each
cotangent space, right?
Because K is a cotangent vector, you
submit it at a point
at uh in um in the cotangent space of X,
and this right-hand side depends
polynomially
on this covector.
That's what you do, and that's we
instructed to do this by mathematicians,
because this is called the principal
polynomial
of these field equations, and it plays
an eminent role in order to understand
them.
I simplify a little bit. If these
equations have um a gauge symmetry, it
works a little differently, but that's
not our concern. It can be done. And the
point of this polynomial is if you know
this polynomial, you understood almost
everything about the causal structure of
this theory.
And I should write down for you the
polynomial in Einstein theory. If you
have from Maxwell theory. If you come
from the Maxwell equations,
the polynomial is P of X, K is the
inverse metric GAB KA KB.
This is the principal polynomial of
Maxwell theory, and expressions like
this we see very often.
It's the principal polynomial. But here,
this is fully general.
Okay, for any matter theory.
Now, if you want to understand the
causal structure, what you do, so when
cotangent space, so we go to one point
of the manifold, and we can do this at
every point, but now I fix one point. We
go to one point, and then what I draw
here is the cotangent space at that
point. It's a vector space, the
cotangent space.
And this shape here, these are the zeros
of the do of the principal polynomial.
So, in Maxwell theory, it's all those K
where this thing is zero. And how does
that look in Maxwell theory?
It looks like that.
Yes. And this K be related to the
generalized momentum in Lagrangian?
It is that one. It uh the K If you do
the geometric optical limit of the field
equations, then this is the wave
covector.
So, it would be the momentum, if you
wish, of the light ray in the geometric
optical limit.
Okay?
So, this is of course a key structure. I
introduced the whole space-time
structure to you via these cones. It's a
key structure. Well, for another theory
that's not Maxwell theory, a bit more
complicated, it could actually look like
this.
Okay? So, then you would have to write
down a gravity theory, a space-time
theory with such a cone. Or it could
look even worse. It could have any type
of shape, right? Uh well, which arises
as the zero shape of such a polynomial
that comes from your matter field
equations. Okay? So, this is the first
thing where you see, okay, there's
something terribly different to the
standard case.
But it could well be that that happens.
For instance, uh a while ago, um it was
claimed that neutrinos run faster than
the speed of light. Have you heard that
in the press?
So, if that had been true, then there
would be a cone from Maxwell theory,
because light would still be there, and
there would have been another cone,
something like this, from the neutrinos.
Well, you see,
it's not excluded that somebody could
have written down equations describing
that. It would be dis- equations where
the zero set of the principal polynomial
that you calculate has this structure.
And people gave interviews in the New
York Times and so on. They said, "Well,
if this is true, then we are at
absolutely at zero. We don't know how to
do any physics anymore." Well, it's not
quite so bad, right? Okay. So, so please
follow the talk.
So, you can have that, and so this is
the kernel, this is the zero set of this
polynomial.
Now, we can play a game, and the game is
I don't want to know the structure in
the cotangent space. I want to know a
rele- a relevant structure induced by it
in the tangent space.
And what you can do, you can look at the
gradients
of this uh surface. And well, if this is
a co- a surface in cotangent space, then
the gradient is a vector.
Well, the gradient in in tangent space
would be a covector, that's what I
always emphasize, but here we are we
already have one star. We have the star
star. The gradient to this surface is a
vector, so we can take this vector and
uh map it by by the actually the
derivative map of this guy
to tangent space. So, that's the origin
of the tangent space at the same point
of the manifold, right? And uh we have
this gradient, and we can draw it in
tangent space. Well, I can take a
gradient at any other point. I can take
this gradient, and I draw it in tangent
space.
And if I do this for all the gradients,
then I get a new figure, a new shape in
tangent space. In this case, you would
get this shape.
Okay? So, that means a shape like this,
the zero set of the principal polynomial
that comes from the field equations,
immediately induces a shape in the
tangent space via this construction.
This is how you do it graphically. Uh
you have to take the fiber derivative if
you want to do it mathematically. Yes.
From what in this cone that we uh uh
know about, we have interpreted this
space the the outside the cone that you
cannot um go there. Particle Yes.
We'll come there. Okay. We'll come
there. We'll come there.
If this is in cotangent space at a point
in Maxwell theory, then the
corresponding picture in tangent space
boringly looks very similar.
Okay?
So, in this case, it looks like this,
and there are other cases where it it
looks more interesting.
Okay. So, anyway, we came from a the
theory this was imposed on us. We can,
however, generate these structures in
the tangent and cotangent space, and
they will have to take the role that
these guys took in Maxwell theory.
Again, why are these structures
important? They're important because
they contain the information about the
causal structure of the theory. I I'll
comment on that further.
And um actually, if you find such this
shape in the tangent space, you can ask,
is there a polynomial in the tangent
space from which, in turn, this shape
derives as the zero set? This was the
zero set of a polynomial here that we
derive from matter field equations. Then
we make this construction, but is there
an underlying polynomial that produces
the shape? And the answer is yes, and
this is called the dual polynomial, and
it's totally determined by this
polynomial. You have a polynomial on a
cotangent space, fine. You have a dual
polynomial on the tangent space.
Well, not always. Not always, but we
will see that our predictivity condition
ensures that if you have a polynomial
here underlying, then they have a
polynomial there underlying, and you can
understand these two shapes by these two
polynomials. And in in Lorentzian
space-time, if here in the cotangent
space the polynomial was essentially
given by the inverse metric, then the
polynomial here is essentially given by
the metric.
But that this is the inverse of this
one, well, that's just kind of an
accident of linear algebra. Uh it should
be more suitably called. If you call
this G inverse, you may call this G
inverse, but the metric is the dual
of the inverse metric. Okay? So, that's
the abstract logic beyond the special
case.
Okay? So, you have this. It's all very
straightforward.
Um
and you have a map that points back.
Okay? So, you can go back and forth, but
careful, not with any vector, only with
a vector that lies or covector that lies
on the surface, you'll map it to a
vector lying on the surface.
Okay.
So, now
I showed you these cones. Somebody wrote
down some theory. We don't know is the
theory predictive? And that's the first
thing you must check if somebody hands
you a theory. And by predictive, I do
not mean does it make the right
predictions we observe? Well, that we
have to check. But the question is,
does the theory predict from data today
actually data tomorrow?
Uh does it even have the power to
predict? And if it has the power to
predict, then you can start questioning
whether it predicts the right thing,
right? It needs to go in that order.
And so, that's the first thing, and the
second thing is that matter is quantum
matter. I said those are the two
bottom-line assumptions we make.
And now, what bearing does that have on
the shape of these guys? How is the
shape restricted? Well, the key result,
first in words, and then I'll show you
what it means, is that if you have
matter field dynamics from which we
started, and you require them to be
predictive, you must have that the
polynomial P in each cotangent space is
a so-called hyperbolic polynomial. What
that is, I'll tell you in a second. It's
an algebraic property that you can
quickly check. Okay? Just I'll explain
it in a second.
Now, it turns out, and so this is long
known. So, this is standard PDE theory,
linear PDE theory, that you actually
predictivity has as a necessary the
hyper-
hyperbolicity of the
principal polynomial. That's why it's so
interesting, right? Because you always
want to decide that.
Now, a new result is that if the matter
field dynamics are quantizable,
a necessary condition for that is that
this dual polynomial
be also a hyperbolic polynomial. It's a
different polynomial
living in the dual space,
but if this polynomial has the property
of being hyperbolic, I'll explain in a
second what it is, then it does by no
means follow that the dual is
hyperbolic.
But if you have that, too, those are
necessary conditions for our basic
assumptions that we make about matter.
Okay? And similarly, you can argue for
point particle dynamics. So, we call
this bihyperbolicity,
and this uh these are two independent
and rather non-negotiable
reasons we should we would like to give
for this
um
hyperbolicity, that the theory is
predictive and quantizable.
Otherwise, you would
throw away the theory in the first
instance.
Okay.
So, this bihyperbolicity is important.
So, I should tell you what this
hyperbolicity condition on the
polynomials is. It's very simple.
I'll explain it geometrically, and then
we can think about what it means
further. Geometrically, it means the
following. Let's start with our familiar
example. We have a light cone, right? It
comes from a second-degree polynomial
metric with Lorentzian signature.
A polynomial with this zero set is
called hyperbolic if there exists a
direction. So, this is the start in
in cotangent space, the origin. There
exists a direction in cotangent space,
this one or this one or this one. There
must be only one. There exists one such
that
I can consider any line in the entire
space that goes in the same direction.
So, there could be a line
that is over here or over here, and it's
an infinite line. Okay? So, there exists
a direction such that every line in this
direction
intersects the surface exactly twice.
Why twice? Well, exactly as often as the
degree of the polynomial is. Because
this is a second-degree polynomial
null surface, there must exist a
direction, if it's hyperbolic, then
there must exist a direction that any
line in that direction intersects the
cone as often as its degree says. And
that's already the general definition of
hyperbolicity. Take this funny thing
here.
There exists a direction, this case this
one for instance, any line in the space,
also the one right over here, right?
Right over here, needs to still
intersect the shape.
This is a fourth-degree polynomial, 1 2
3 4 times.
Let's go back here. This direction here
is not a direction that identifies this
as a hyperbolic
polynomial, because the line here
doesn't touch the cone at all. Now, the
cone is here like this, like this.
And this line runs over here. It just
simply doesn't touch it.
Yes.
Pardon me?
Yes. So, the point is what happens if
you come to the origin here, it seems to
intersect only once, but you count them
not geometrically, but algebraically.
So, the algebraic multiplicity, there
are two zeros here, two roots. Okay?
That's the the counting scheme.
So, it's very simple to decide that, and
um
in fact, the set of all the directions
that have this property that any line in
that direction intersects as often as
the polynomial says has an interesting
is an interesting structure for us is
called the hyperbolicity cone.
And it's those guys here, and also the
guys that point down here. So, in normal
language we'd say the time-like vectors
or something like this. Okay? But we
don't call them like this. Maybe you
realized I I withstood calling them a
lot like this.
Um
The hyperbolicity cone is so it's not
the total set, but it's the zero doesn't
belong to it. It's the it's a connected
component of such vectors. So, either
this one or that one, you can pick.
Well, they're both hyperbolicity cones.
Later on we'll make a pick. In the
picture over there, the hyperbolicity
cone is actually only the set inside
here.
So, although this is a very complicated
structure, and it can be arbitrarily
complicated, you always have a hyper if
the polynomial is hyperbolic, there's a
hyperbolicity cone. There's one, and
there is also another in this case here.
And this is by a theorem by Gårding,
famous theorem, is always an open and a
convex cone. So, whatever crazy
polynomial you have, for us physicists,
whatever matter theory you have you come
from, it's an open and a convex cone.
That's very important. This is an open
and a convex cone. It's extremely
important that it's open and convex.
You tell me later on or somewhere in the
tutorial, somebody, why if it's not
convex, why you have a stability with
photons.
Okay. Anyway, so that's very important,
that's always guaranteed for these guys,
and they're hyperbolic. Remember, P is
hyperbolic if the theory is predictive.
So, the stability of photons has a lot
to do with the predictivity of the
theory. Anyway,
so
Now, what I already showed you is if you
have these cones, they are they
correspond to say the the wave vectors
and the light-like vectors, right? In
cotangent tangent space, you can map the
null covectors, the P null covectors to
the P null vectors like by this fiber
map I had before, right?
But now we want to do something
different. So, I have this I can map the
brown stuff to the yellow stuff, but no
other vector in the cotangent space can
be mapped over here.
Or otherwise, from here, no other vector
can be mapped back to here. By the way,
this is of course raising and lower
raising and lowering of indices, right?
Do you see this? If you go here,
this is the raising and the lowering of
indices. Only here, in general, it's
nonlinear.
But it exists. But I can only raise and
lower indices on the brown and the
yellow stuff. That's not good enough. I
also need to know how to raise an index
on these covectors. How to go over
there.
And that's not possible by the same map.
And instead, what you need is a
so-called Legendre map that's also a
fiber derivative, but of the ln of the
polynomial.
And its image might lie rather ugly in
an ugly way over here, but that's just a
fact of life.
In the Maxwell case here, it's actually
very simple. There, also the outer
vectors, the null vectors, are mapped
with one type of map over here.
And the vectors inside the cone are
mapped by an entirely different type of
map, namely by a Legendre map to over
here. It's only by accident, because the
structure is so simple, that the maps
numerically, I almost would like to say
numerically coincide. So, they're
usually thought of as being one in the
same map that maps the null vectors, and
it maps the time-like vectors.
We always use the metric for that. And
even worse, one has a meaning of taking
a vector out here, and you can still,
because it's linear algebra, you can
extend this linear map rate that raises
the index
to also mapping
space-like covectors to space-like
vectors.
And all seems to be the same thing.
Well, here it simply isn't. As soon as
the structure is a little bit more
complicated, as your matter theory might
dictate, it's not as simple, and you
discover they're structurally different
things.
So, this is now for the inside of a
hyperbolicity cone, you go over there,
and you arrive there, and in fact, you
can show, or we showed, that if both the
polynomial and its dual are both
hyperbolic,
as a physicist you should think, ah, if
the matter theory is predictive and
quantizable. Okay, check, I want that.
If this is the case, then also the
inverse of this map exists and is
unique.
Meaning,
if you get these structures for some
matter type,
only if the matter is predictive and
quantizable, which is however exactly
what we want, do you have a theory of
raising and lowering indices also on
elements in the browns in the brown
areas here.
Okay?
Only remains the question, what about
the vectors that lie neither on the
boundary here, on the null surface, nor
in here?
Maybe here outside or here in between,
and the answer is we don't know. It's
probably not possible, and we don't
care. It's not important. My claim is,
also in standard theory, you never need
to raise the index
of a space-like vector. Has no physical
meaning. You can do it, because your
linear map extends to it. So, if you can
do it, do it if you must, but there is
no point in the theory where you need to
do that. But you need very often to
raise and lower the index on a null
vector on a time-like vector, a covector
here, right?
Okay. So, the Legendre This one is
called the Gauss map for historical
reasons, and this one is called the
Legendre map. And again, in the standard
theory they coincide, so nobody talks
about the difference, but there's a huge
difference, because the Gauss map is
actually something
from projective algebraic geometry.
Algebraic geometry is the study of the
zero surfaces of polynomials.
And the Legendre map is an object from
convex analysis. So, because we always
have open and convex cones, we have
Legendre maps. Yes.
Yes.
No, no, no, no, no. So, in convex
analysis, no, no. It's not We found the
inverse for the Legendre map. This is
well-established theory, but the point
is, in this context, right? It's one
needs to work a little to see that it
can be applied.
Okay? So, in this context, coming in
space-time for hyperbolic polynomials,
so you can have a Legendre map for any
convex function on a convex cone, or
rather stricter conditions if the cone
has a boundary. So, normally in
classical mechanics, where we do the
Legendre transformation to go to the
Hamiltonian formalism, or in
statistical physics, where they do the
Legendre transformation to go to other
potentials, right? You always act on a
whole vector space,
space, and a whole vector space is a
special case of a cone. A cone is like I
think I explained this before, it's like
a vector subspace. So, you can the sum
of two vectors in a cone is again a
vector in the cone, and the positive
multiples of a vector are in the cone.
Well, that's of course true for the
entire vector space, and then some
subtleties of the Legendre
transformation are not seen. So,
therefore we think, oh, you can always
do the Legendre transformation.
Actually, if the domain is a cone with a
boundary, that's a little more
restricted. Okay.
Anyway, so the message I want to convey
is very simple. You come from some
matter model that you propose, if it's
predictive and quantizable, the
polynomial must be bihyperbolic. As a
polynomial must be hyperbolic, and the
dual polynomial must be hyperbolic, too.
If it isn't, you can immediately throw
out the theory.
Yes.
a faster than light neutrinos, would
they
still be moving this ground stuff? Well,
yeah. I mean, you could for instance I
mean, this is a special cone. If you had
a cone like this one, then the
hyperbolicity cone, so a double cone
like this, the hyperbolicity cone would
be like here. You could think that light
runs here and that the neutrinos then
run here and there is no problem.
Well, that is I say there's no problem.
You have these structures, right? You
might here in the first case think which
is the relevant cone. Well, for what
it's worth, it's this
hyperbolicity cone, but this stuff is
also there. I show you how to deal with
this, okay? That's the purpose of the
whole talk, but absolutely, if you had
Maxwell theory and neutrinos and the
cone structure was that simple, it could
be even more complicated to explain the
case. We know how to deal with it. It's
not a big mystery. It's not the theory
is totally dead. Well, general
relativity is, but the general idea
isn't. That's what I'm trying to
explain. Okay.
So, we have this Legendre map, too.
Now, we have the complicated cone
structure, what's the physical
significance?
I just need to tell you this. You trust
me that this is true. We checked this.
We have many theorems
proven on that. It's roughly as follows.
So, you have the cotangent space, you
have this polynomial and the null
covectors are the momenta of massless
particles. Well, this doesn't surprise
you very much because that is exactly
what it is here. But it is that not
because we generalize from here, but
because this is the general idea of
massless momenta from geometric
from the geometric limit of optics. So,
it's rather like because in the general
case, the massless momenta lie here,
that's also the explanation why they lay
lie there. Did I explain to you why the
massless momenta are the covectors on
the on the null cone? I didn't. Okay.
This is the explanation. That's the
reason. And the moment the covectors in
the hyperbolicity cone are the momenta
of massive particles. Again, that fully
coincides here with the so-called
time-like covectors being the covectors
of massive particles. Then you map them
over here, then you get the tangent
vectors of null particles of massless
particles and you get the tangent
vectors of massive particles. Okay? And
the space-like
covectors
of what should they be the momenta?
And their image under raising the index,
the space-like vectors, of what should
they be the tangent vectors? Well,
certainly not of matter.
You don't need it.
Okay? That's the reason why you don't
need it. Anyway, you have this.
And then you go to the dual space, to
the tangent space, and there you have
again the massless particle velocities
as I just said and the image of this
cone, which does not coincide with the
hyperbolicity cone here, which in
general is bigger than that, that's the
massive particle velocities.
The fact that this one is bigger than
this inner cone here
has funny consequences. For instance, in
general theories that are not precisely
this one, you can have massive observers
that run alongside some component of
light. For instance, in this
birefringent electrodynamics,
this would not be different matter, but
would be one and the other polarization
component of light running like this or
this. This is why it does that.
So, in matter
this is reality, okay?
In vacuum, we don't know, but in matter,
it already looks like this.
Huh? So, this is not fantasy. This you
if you're a material physicist, you say,
"Okay, yeah, yeah, I I know this stuff."
I mean, not in this form they don't, but
um
morally morally.
Okay. But here, so you can run with
massive matter along one component of
light and you can even run faster than
some component of light. You just cannot
run faster than the fastest light. That
you can't do.
Okay? And that gives you effects like
Cherenkov radiation
in here,
but if this also happens in vacuum, also
there.
Now, you say, "Okay, why would it happen
in vacuum?
It happens in matter." Well, who would
have thought that in vacuum you could
have lensing?
Right? So, it's just the assumption is
only like maybe the vacuum is as rich in
structure as matter is. I mean, it could
be possible, right?
Anyway, so this is the the picture here
and that's the physical significance of
these.
Now, what is the meaning of this
hyperbolicity cone here? Well, it's the
velocities of possible observers.
You know that in standard general
relativity, the observer always runs
along a time-like
curve.
A time-like curve is of course the
hyperbolicity cone of the dual.
So, you say, "Oh, yeah, all the matter
and all the observers all on time-like
curves."
Well, here it turns out not any matter
can act as an observer.
Why not?
Well, first of all, they can't,
otherwise the whole picture becomes
ill-defined, so it's a constraint that
comes from a well-definition of the
theory. And if you then calculate what
happens to the matter that runs faster
than a than an observer, you see that it
will very quickly radiate away.
So, you could say, poetically, you can
break the speed limit, the lower speed
limit, but you pay a price for it.
You radiate away.
Okay? So, in nature, we wouldn't see
much of these particles because they
would immediately radiate away. They
would immediately lose energy to the
electromagnetic field, say, and fall
back into here, which would have been if
this had been true with the superluminal
neutrinos, would have been a beautiful
explanation why never anybody saw them
before.
Because they're very unstable. And so,
we were surprised why they would be so
stable and therefore we didn't believe
the result. Other people didn't believe
the result for other reasons. In fact,
the result was wrong because they didn't
plug the socket right or something. But
uh
um but but this is the case. So, I'm
just talking about things that could
come up from matter theories, right?
Just talking about this. I'm not saying
this is how nature is or this is my
proposal for nature. I say, "If you
write down new matter theories, they can
be perfectly predictive, perfectly
quantizable and have this feature."
Well, maybe we'll have to live with that
feature.
Right?
So, usually it's assumed if the theory
isn't like this, it's not predictive.
That's just wrong. Right? Open any
mathematics book.
Okay. Yes.
So, the the inverse of the Legendre map
has a bigger domain than the
hyperbolicity cone in the or can have a
bigger domain. Uh uh then the hyperbole
Yes, that's right. So, when when you
started out with the principal
polynomial, you wrote the indices on the
coefficients up, so that suggests that
we plug in a covector, but there is no
like
necessity to plug in a covector. You
could have also wrote the indices down
on the coefficients as vectors.
Yes. Yep. That's just a Yes, you have to
keep in mind whether it's the velocity
of a massless or a massive particle.
There's a very easy thing I can ask an
exam question
which I of course won't ask because it's
just a special case of this theory, is
is this a tangent vector of a
of a massive or a massless particle? You
say, "Well, of course, it's of a massive
particle."
Well, in that theory, you don't really
know.
Well, you do because I mean, okay. For
for this one you do. If I ask, "Is this
the
the the tangent vector of a massless
particle?" Here you say yes. In that
theory, you don't really know because
there could be other massless particles
and this could be either the velocity of
a massive particle, meaning having this
momentum, and the very same tangent
vector could be the tangent vector
could be the tangent vector of a
massless particle. These two are mapped
to this one.
And they say, "Okay, so it's two to
one." No, because this one is mapped
with the Legendre map to here and this
one is mapped with the Gauss map. And
under the inverse of the Gauss map, this
one will go back here and under the
inverse of the Legendre map, this one
will go here. There is no problem.
But it confuses one at first sight
because one is used to be able to tell.
Right? But why would you be able to tell
from just a picture? You need to keep it
in mind. Well, the theory has it in mind
anyway.
Okay? So, there is confusion that come
up precisely because of that and
therefore I emphasize the different
character of these maps.
Again, nothing if this is a model. This
is all mathematics. It just must be like
that.
Okay.
So, at this point, we arrive at a
refined physical definition of
space-time. Remember, I provided in the
course at the beginning this definition
of space-time as a Lorentz manifold,
blah blah blah blah, okay?
Now, we have a refined definition
of which of course the definition I gave
you is a special case, but leaves out
important aspects.
Space-time is a triple. Well, for us it
was whatever it was uh
a 16 member
uh tuple.
Um
I have of course here a smooth manifold.
So, the O and the A and so on, you you
all keep in mind. So, it's a smooth
manifold.
But that's is a smooth manifold, then I
have some
tensor G which I call the geometry. It
could have four indices like here. It
could have 26 indices, 10 up and 16
down. Could have all crazy symmetries.
It could be several of those, right? I
mean, this is just
to convey the idea.
And all of that we had before. We have
the smooth manifold, we had a geometric
structure, was a Lorentz metric a
special case.
But I did not say that a space-time
consists of a smooth manifold and a
geometric structure
and a matter action. I didn't talk about
matter actions until very late, you
remember?
In fact, what I should have written is
space time is a smooth manifold with a
Lorentzian metric in order to introduce
the standard theory and the Maxwell
action.
Why?
Because I do not have the slightest clue
how to interpret this structure if I do
not use matter to probe it.
I can say, I can claim in this room here
we have a Riemannian metric. I mean, in
space time, in our portion of there's a
Riemannian metric, plus plus plus plus
plus.
And then we can have long philosophical
discussions whether that's a good idea
or not.
But what you really have to do, you have
to check.
You have to use matter to probe the
structure of space time. For instance,
you have to look at Mercury, that's
matter. It goes around the sun and it
makes this little
procession and so on. So you say, ah,
okay, so if I really want to understand
this and with the light deflection and
so on,
there must be a Lorentzian metric. Then
I have Maxwell theory, it must be a
Lorentzian metric because Maxwell theory
on a Riemannian metric is not
predictive.
The hyperbolicity in the metric case
means Lorentzian signature. That's the
next thing that's explained.
So if you ask, why do we take a
Lorentzian metric? Actually, somebody
asked me that the other day. There's a
very clear answer.
If you do Maxwell theory on a non Lor-
on a metric background, but it's not a
Lorentz metric, then from initial data
you cannot predict the future data. You
simply cannot.
Okay? Here's the explanation for the
Lorentz signature, but in general it's
not there's nothing about signature,
it's about the bi-hyperbolicity of the
polynomial. So I say, if you want to
talk about space time in a meaningful
way, say it's this manifold, say it's
this geometric structure,
but then tell me which matter you use
and only that gives meaning to the
geometric structure.
So it's a smooth manifold
so field G which we call the geometry
because we like to and a test matter
action, matter that probes this.
And this triple must be such that the
associated
principal polynomial and its dual that
you get from the matter action are both
hyperbolic. So this is in a sense the
Lorentzian condition in the metric case.
In the if you take a metric a Maxwell
theory, that's the Lorentzian condition.
And of course you can write and you need
a time orientation, da da da da da, you
can all put on top. This is the
essential thing.
It makes no sense to ask, is space time
maybe
does it maybe have this structure?
You need to ask, does it have this
structure combined with that and that
matter theory being coupled to this
structure? Then we start talking and
then you're closer to experiment.
The question whether metric the space
time geometry is a metric geometry is a
philosophical question.
How would I ever test this? Use matter,
so you need to provide the matter in
order to make a coherent whole. So
matter and space time are not so
separated as one thinks, not even in the
basic interpretation.
And if you now think historically, this
is exactly what happened. Einstein
stared at the Maxwell equations and he
saw, oh, there's this relativistic stuff
in there and the whole interpretation of
observers and measurements and all of
that
was fixed. Einstein didn't dream this
up, it was fixed by the Maxwell
equations and this formalizes this. But
we don't need a new Einstein to do this,
we just look at the mathematical
structure of the theory, we say, okay,
we do it like Einstein, but with the
mathematics we have here, okay? So
that's the that's the good thing.
And so what I want to emphasize is that
the physicality of the assumed space
time geometry
depends on the matter.
I have here three exclamation marks,
always difficult to remember. So I think
the first exclamation mark is that I
say, isn't that remarkable? Isn't that
remarkable that we need to provide
matter in order to understand what we're
even talking about, even if I put the
geometry on the table.
Second, it's remarkable because it
explains so many of the questions some
people did ask and other questions
people could have asked. Why do you use
a metric? Well, because it underlies
Maxwell theory. Why do you use a
Lorentzian metric? Well, because
otherwise Maxwell theory is not
predictive. Why do you raise and lower
the indices like this? Well, because you
always need to because that's the
duality between the spaces. Why do you
raise and lower null and time like
vector indices and co-vector indices and
vector indices
in the same way? I say, well, that's an
accident.
Okay? That is not generic. But you see,
the history of modifying gravity, of
doing it differently is a long and
winding one
and many proposals have been put forward
by Einstein himself, for instance, to
have a non-symmetric metric tensor. He
says, why would this metric be symmetric
in its two indices? Maybe if we have a
non-symmetric one, we have more degrees
of freedom, maybe we can have a better
theory that explains more, is more
refined and so on.
And then they started constructing
inverses of this object, right? And that
is where the whole trouble starts
because why do you do an inverse? Well,
because that's
structural, the formal analogy to what
you do in GR. Well, formal analogies
mean very little. You need to understand
why you did it in GR like this and then
you can follow the why and do it the
same, but don't just copy something
formal. In fact, what you need, you
don't know how to go from here to here
unless you have matter. If you have
matter, it's the matter that tells you
how to go from here to here. It's the
principal polynomial that tells you how
to go from here to here. But the
principal polynomial you get from this
structure G
only by looking at matter whose
principal polynomial that is.
And so then one understands why on
Earth, if you have a matter action, say
for a point particle, why you actually
need to write
why the point particle has actually this
Lagrangian.
Why does it have this Lagrangian? Well,
because if you from this Lagrangian you
see how you have to raise and lower
indices, you know that the momentum
index
is something
like this, you pull the index on the
velocity and you get the momentum. But
the velocity is a kinematical quantity
and the momentum always
depends on your Lagrangian, you know
that from classical mechanics. You
cannot calculate a momentum without
knowing the dynamics. Well, but if this
is the association of momenta to
velocities, how on Earth would you make
them if you don't know what matter
you're talking about?
You see, a lot of the stuff we're doing
by raising, lowering indices and vectors
go to co-vectors, we do this as if this
was written in stone on a Lorentzian
manifold. This is only like this because
we always substitute Maxwell theory as
the one theory that tells us how things
go.
Okay?
Okay, so this is the physicality of the
assumed
space time.
So, um, and that's only a slight, you
see, this is a slight redefinition, it
actually is not a redefinition, it just
makes precise what before we just
introduced tacitly, usually with the
statement, this is what Einstein told
us.
Okay? So, so so far again I emphasize,
this is maximally conservative, it's
only
studying what underlies the standard
theory logically, but once you
understand this, you can apply it to any
matter theory and that's the beauty of
it. Especially the beauty, in fact, of
having so much matter around us that we
don't understand matter and energy. Who
knows? Who knows? We are prepared here.
Okay, so this is this thing, you
understand the space time if you
understand matter on it and before that
you understand very little.
Now,
everything is fine for a given space
time geometry, I now understand how this
works. But how on Earth is this
new structure that you identify by
looking at matter that requires it,
how on Earth are you going to give this
new structure dynamics?
Also, that has been undertaken quite a
lot. Einstein, Schrödinger, Eddington,
Moffat,
and hundreds of people have tried to
formulate new gravitational dynamics for
new geometric structures.
It's not
it's not an idea that wouldn't present
itself. The question is, how do you do
it?
And I think in the past people followed
too much the formal analogies and always
ran against some wall or the other.
Well, so let's try to do a little better
than that.
So let's go to gravitational dynamics.
Well,
so this goes very close to what Nico
Giulini was telling you about the
standard theory,
um, but I will try to explain
independently of what he said because I
do not assume that all of you fully
studied that because it's excluded from
the exam. But you should, it was a
fantastic lecture and actually what he
said is a very important point of
understanding gravity, but I'll start
anew.
Let's look at space time.
So again, as always, I have to reduce
one dimension because otherwise I cannot
draw a picture of space time. But let's
assume here this three-dimensional space
is a picture of space time and I start
with the view, maybe a little
Western-centric, of an internal God.
Okay.
So how would an internal God view space
time? Well, he just looks at it, tada,
there it is. And he knows the history of
the entire universe. So if there's a
particle running here, well, so this is,
uh, 2,000 years ago, this is today, this
goes on. Just God, this is
just boom, looks at it and he knows
everything at once. Okay? This is, uh,
a view and this is a little bit, uh, the
megalomaniac view of theoretical
physicists who say space is a
four-dimensional manifold, the world
line is there and
okay.
But in a sense in space-time nothing
happens because it just boom is. Okay?
Um obviously if we had if we could
afford this view
we wouldn't need physics
cuz I can predict by looking.
Aha, tomorrow this is going to happen,
right? So
Okay.
Now however, if you're God then
it's lonely up there. And
so what you could do, you could play a
game.
And God says, "Okay, just for fun,
let's in my space-time which I overview,
let's put some arbitrary surfaces. Okay.
And he might put their surfaces that are
such that the co-vector is always
the dual vector to a to a tangent to a
world line. In other words, he could
say, let's take a space-time
hypersurface. I don't know why God would
be interested in space-like Sorry, in
space-like hypersurfaces, but let's
assume he does. That's the game he
plays.
And he has this big geometry sitting in
space. It could be a metric, a
Lorentzian metric for instance, and he
decides to look at the metric it induces
on these
surfaces. It's a little bit like me
saying, "Oh, let's put a little sphere
here and let's study how the sphere
works, right?" There's a little bit Why
would I do that? Well, I I'm bored. So I
study spheres. Okay? So he's bored and
he studies the spatial hypersurfaces
just for fun.
And he knows okay, he knows the induced
geometry on this one, on this one
because they all come from the big
space-time geometry we're also
interested in.
And then he continues the game he says,
"Aha,
wouldn't it be funny to study
how the geometry on here changes if I
slightly deform this hypersurface by a
lapse N and by a shift shift N alpha.
You remember that from Giulini's
lecture? So you
shift it up a little bit everywhere and
then you move it a little bit and then
you have an infinitesimally close other
one.
Now God plays this game in two ways. He
said, "Well, I produced other surface
and then I just look what is there
because he can look.
But he can say, "But it's a funny game.
I take the data here and I just say how
I deform the surface and I calculate
by derivatives how it looks like. And
then I compare and I calculate it right.
Okay? Of course, all this is totally
silly when God plays this game. It's
really just because it's so boring up
there. Okay? So that's the God view and
of obviously I will come back to this
point, right? So it's a it's a
pedagogical game.
So that's God. Now we have us
or some of us.
The homo sapiens.
And our access to space-time is
different. Our access is we have a very
short lifetime or our experiments have a
very short lifetime. We switch them off,
on and then we're off again. So this a
little bit this kind of pace. And
because of the short lifetime and also
because of the finite length of my arms,
I have only limited access to space
around me.
So however big you are and long-lived,
you experience something like this. And
also the experience of any experimental
apparatus we have. What's the longest
running experiment in history?
Gerhard?
Well, if you don't know, I don't know. I
don't know. But anyway, it looks a
little bit
It looks a little bit like that. Okay?
So we have a problem if we want to
compete with God in knowing what's going
on up here, we're at a serious
disadvantage.
Very serious. We just don't know.
Now this is homo sapiens. Now homo
sapiens sapientissimus, right?
Says, "Okay, this
little piece of cake this too complicate
for me. I make a little abstraction. I
linearize
what happens away from right now. I
linearize that. So instead of collecting
data in the piece of cake, he collects
data on the plate on which the cake is
served and he linearly approximates
what's happening in the cake by
providing to these initial data also
initial velocities.
Roughly speaking. And that can also
apply to the geometry, right? And
Giulini showed this, right? He had the
geometric fields and he had the momentum
fields. It's a bit funny what how
geometry has a momentum, but if geometry
is just a field, why wouldn't it have a
momentum, right? So but this is just a
linearization
of we know a little more. But if you
want to measure the momentum or say the
velocity of a bird, you look once and
you look again and you need a finite
lifetime to do that.
If you just live in one instant, you can
never see velocities. You just see the
picture and then you're dead. Okay? But
but if you live a little longer, you can
look look again and then you can
approximate a velocity. Well, that's
roughly this. Okay? So giving initial
conditions consisting of a position and
a velocity is the first step to
competing with God because the velocity
tells you what happens the very next
moment.
But that you still get by observation,
you must get by observation.
Okay. Now you have the initial
conditions here, position and momentum
or velocity or in geometry initial
geometry and the first order change of
the geometry, but then your life is
over.
Okay?
More or less.
Now how do you compete with God? Well,
you still are not very close to
competing with him of saying what
happens here. He just looks and you're
dead.
What do you do? What brings you closer
to God?
A Hamiltonian.
A Hamiltonian brings you closer to what
The Hamiltonian eats the initial
conditions
and evolves them.
Isn't that what Hamiltonian mechanics
Okay, this is it now geometry and
velocity. Let's say it's geometry and
momentum, it's the same thing. It devel-
evolves the initial conditions.
So we need Hamiltonians or Lagrangians
or whatever is equivalent or equations
of motion because we're not God, because
we're human. Humans need equations of
motions in order to say from the now
what is the tomorrow. Is that right?
That's exactly it.
Haha, we're we're close. So
how do we Now the question is, what is
the Hamiltonian? What is the Hamiltonian
that brings me from here to there? Well,
that's exactly the question we're asking
in this lecture. What is the Hamiltonian
of the new gravity theory? Or of the old
gravity theory for that matter. What is
it?
Well, it's the Hamiltonian that makes
you compete with God.
So now we come back to our little God
game here. Giulini actually explained
this well, he mentioned it. He said this
constraint algebra. Do you remember the
H's and the D's? The constraint algebra
he said you can get from purely
kinematical deformation algebras. You
don't need to know the dynamics first,
you just know the geometry and you know
how to deform one hypersurface in the
other and you know how to study how the
data changes.
If you know that, you can write down the
constraint algebra. Okay. Now
let's look at this.
So
the play a game God is playing is
actually he's embedding Giulini called
this little E sub T, I call it X sub T.
You're embedding the same space spatial
manifold, the same three manifold again
and again and again into space-time in a
certain way. In which way? It doesn't
matter. Must be space-like surfaces,
right?
You do embed that.
And then you choose coordinates on your
space-time and you choose coordinates on
your abstract three manifold. Okay? And
actually that is that is the path you
actually give it.
So and now the geometry on here is just
the pullback of the metric from up here
along this embedding map.
It's a pullback.
Okay, so that's the game God is playing
a little bit more diagrammatically, but
we did all of that, right? We did
pullbacks and stuff like that.
Now God's game that I explained before
can be expressed in terms of deformation
operators.
What do you do? Well, let's start with
this one. This is the tangential
deformation operator. Did he call it H
and D? How did he call it?
Aha.
Okay.
Anyway, the deformation operators
um
Here you use you say this is the N
alpha, that's the shift and the lapse
appears up here. That tells you at every
point of the manifold embedded manifold
how much you go to the side
and this N here tells you how much you
go up. But let's start with how much you
go to the side in the direction of the
tangent vectors. All fine. And this is
just a functional derivative that acts
on the geometry. Roughly speaking, this
tells you how these data change if you
go a little bit to the right. You can
only calculate it when you're God
because you need the functional
derivative, but derivatives mean you
need to know it here in order to
compare. Okay? But anyway, that's the
game God plays.
A little bit more interesting is this
one. You have here the deformation this
direction and the tangent vectors down
here to a hypersurface. They're always
given. You have a hypersurface embedding
and you can always calculate the tangent
vectors.
But here what you need is a normal
vector.
But a normal vector you cannot you don't
get for free. If you have a
hypersurface,
what you can calculate is a co-normal.
You can calculate a normal co-vector
which if you feed in all the tangent
vectors, annihilates it.
In other words, you can calculate the
gradient to the hypersurface, but the
gradient is a covector, okay? We know
that.
Aha, so if this is embedded and the
gradient is a covector, we have a
problem because in order to go away from
the hypersurface in a certain direction,
we need to convert the covector, which
is more like something like this, into a
vector.
Which is exactly
this kind of map.
You need to take a hyperbolic covector.
Why a hyperbolic one? Because there is
the theorem that a hype an initial data
surface must always have a covector, I
indicate like this, that lies in the
cotangent space inside the hyperbolicity
cone.
So in order to convert the normal, the
gradient to an initial data surface,
that's the game we're playing here,
in order to convert that gradient into a
direction,
you need to know how to go from here to
here. Agree?
But how do you know to go from there to
there? You only know if you have matter,
if you understand your matter, only then
do you really know that.
Thank God we postulated matter in our
definition of spacetime. It's the matter
we postulated and it will depend on that
matter through its principal polynomial
of how the hypersurface
gradient is converted into a direction
that co can go into here so that you
know what you mean by a normal
deformation.
So in this whole picture, there is one
single point where physics comes in.
This is all clear, this is all logically
clear, but where's the physics coming
in? The physics comes in right here.
The construction of this normal vector
is actually the Legendre image
of the gradient of the normal covector
of the gradient to the surface. But this
Legendre map was, in general terms, not
in Einstein theory, but quite generally,
the Legendre map was the fiber
derivative of the ln of the polynomial.
And the inverse Legendre map going back
was that of the dual polynomial.
Okay?
So the Legendre map
takes you there. But this P is the
principal polynomial of the matter you
have on your spacetime.
So that means
if God is playing this game in this
divine view of spacetime,
then we can compete with him if we know
that the direction that's chosen here is
this one. You say, why would this This
is the conversion from momentum to
velocity. That is right.
That is right. It's the conversion of
momentum to velocities for time-like, uh
so for massive momenta.
That's right. That's right. And this is
the one and only step we identify here
and there will be no further where
physics goes into the derivation of
gravity.
Exactly, then it comes from matter.
Gravity comes from matter in precisely
this point.
Okay, good. So, aha, so we have that.
Now God plays his game with these linear
functional derivative operators, okay,
that's an easy game. We unfortunately
have to play a more complicated game. We
have to represent this here not on the
space of all geometries on the
spacetime, we have to represent it as a
Poisson bracket action on initial data.
You know that if you do a Hamiltonian,
well, you can think of this to first
order as a a Hamiltonian acting on
positions, you know what you get. You
get the Q dots and so on. Now it turns
out the Hamiltonian of gravity is the
sum of these two, that's what you
actually can check in Giulini's lecture
for the special case of Einstein gravity
coming from the dynamics, we have to
represent these operators here by
Poisson bracket operators where one slot
is filled with two representations of
these two objects
in order to evolve. Well, that's the
game we have to play, Hamiltonian
dynamics.
But how on earth are these two guys to
be chosen?
How does the world work?
Well, if you look at this, you say,
"Aha, we could calculate the algebra of
these guys
and require that these guys satisfy the
same algebra."
Because that's the information that's in
there. So let's do that. You take these
guys, these deformation operators, and
you calculate from them the deformation
algebra.
Now here, this is the degree of the
polynomial. This is the polynomial, if
you ask, "Why does it only have two
indices? If a higher degree polynomial
should have many more indices." Well,
these are these two and the remaining
ones are filled with the K vector.
Anyway, this is
the general notion. In Einstein gravity,
you have degree P is two and this is the
inverse of the spatial metric on your
hypersurface. But this works, this comes
out, this is a calculation, this works
in our fully general theory. And it must
work like that for mathematical reasons.
So you have an algebra, it's the algebra
of God's little game operators. In order
to compete with him, these objects must
satisfy the same algebra because
otherwise you're playing a different
game.
So we want to impose this algebra on
these objects and then we can actually
determine these two objects, the ones
that represent that, and that is
something we did.
And it's a very complicated problem
because in this algebra the H's appear
squared. I mean, you see HH, it's a
quadratic problem in the H. It's very
difficult and it's not even a Lie
algebra, I think Giulini also emphasized
that, um because uh here there are no
structure constants, they're structure
functions.
So it's not a Lie algebra and that makes
it very, very difficult and hard uh
despite the uh space on which this is
formulated being infinite dimensional
geometry space, whatever, the point is a
hard problem.
But once you solve the problem, I'll
show you in a second how to do that, you
get these two objects and the
gravitational action, one can show,
looks like this.
Meaning, you start with matter, you
calculate the principal polynomial, you
put it into here, that's the only thing
you really need from the matter at the
end of the day.
You put it into here, you calculate the
algebra, this is always the same
algebra, you don't even need to repeat
the step, you start from here and you
find this representation.
Once you have that, you have the gravity
Lagrangian. You found the Hamiltonian of
the geometry.
Right? Now, how do you solve this very
complicated representation problem?
Well, as I said, it's a quadratic
representation problem.
You can convert it into a linear
distribution function differential
equation, still terribly difficult. A
linear distribution differential
equation, still too difficult. You can
finally convert this into a linear, even
homogeneous linear system of partial
differential equations. The price you
pay is it's uncountably infinitely many.
Okay? And that's the system you have to
solve and here it is.
Okay?
Now, the point is this looks terrible,
but it's not bad. So
this is the Lagrangian of gravity and
you
expand it in this case and you want to
calculate these coefficients capital C.
If you have them, you have the
Lagrangian.
Now for these coefficients capital C
with varying number of indices, you have
six equations. That's not finitely
infinitely many, you have six.
And then you have five sequences.
Uh so that's five times infinity, okay?
So you have in total infinitely many
equations and the C's in there are the
ones you want to determine because
they're the coefficients of your
Lagrangian expansion. And the other
coefficients, the U and the S and the T
and the V and whatever names we gave
them,
you simply calculate from the principal
polynomial.
It's a recipe. It's one
A4 page recipe. Blah blah blah blah
blah. It's very boring, so Max can tell
you about how boring it is.
So
you you calculate that for the matter
type you have.
Okay?
And then you solve the resulting
equations always have this form, it's
only these coefficients change to the
equation coefficients and then you
calculate these C's that are the
coefficients up here.
And then you have your gravity theory.
Now um
I mean, actually it is fun to solve that
stuff.
Particular, say you start with Maxwell
theory, you calculate this polynomial,
you go in, you calculate the the U V M Q
T and S coefficients, you plug them in,
you still have infinitely many
equations, need to be very organized,
and then you start solving them.
And then you solve them and if you start
with Maxwell theory, tada, in the end
what comes out is that the L up there
expanded in the C's is the square root
of minus G R plus lambda over all factor
one over, well,
let's say one over G.
Undetermined because it's a system of
differential equations, you have
integration constants, undetermined, you
have integration constants, but that is
it.
Okay? If you start with Maxwell theory.
So Einstein gravity is the gravity
theory that produces solutions
that are such that
Maxwell theory can live on it and is
predictive and quantizable.
That's the game.
Now, so the point is the problem of
finding a gravity theory is not working
in a patent office, it's actually
solving these equations.
Okay?
So if you have new matter
that you
for like Maxwell, think always, people
talk of Maxwell theory fundamental
theory like the other standard model.
What do you mean by fundamental theory?
All physics is phenomenology.
There comes Ampere and there comes
Faraday and they work with their little
magnets. I mean, you actually in in
fact, so if you think what this really
means.
You work with you know these experiments
from high school. You have a current
running through a wire and you put your
little magnetic needles around it and
they arrange themselves in in this
shape. And the other thing is you have a
dynamo on your on your bike and it
produces light. Okay? Because it turns a
magnet and tralala.
Ampere and Faraday, two very simple
things. You put them together, if you're
Maxwell, you say, "Okay, there's a
current term missing, the displacement
current in order to get the continuity
equation right." Okay, minor stuff,
peanuts. Okay. So, you put this
together, but it's actually these two
experiments that you do in high school
that everybody knows actually about it.
That imply
this.
Which implies the Big Bang.
I mean, this is an amazing stretch
of connection, right?
It's quite remarkable. Okay, but now
assume maybe today the people who look
at dark matter or dark energy more
likely the candidate.
You look at this and one day some new
Faraday and Ampere will come and say,
"Well, I have these nice little
equations that explain this stuff." And
then a new Maxwell comes and says,
"Okay, and seriously people, let's put
this together in a meaningful way."
Whatever, whatever the windings of
history will be. And I'm fantasizing
very clearly. It could all be very very
simple, but it could be like they write
down new equations. Well, what to do
then? Well, very simple. You calculate
the principal polynomial, plug them into
these equations here and you solve these
equations. However easy or hard that
will be.
Or other alternative, NASA is looking
for this. They're looking for
birefringence in vacuum and they don't
find it. Okay? And so, they're bounds on
that and so on. But I ask, "How would
you find it? You don't even have a
theory that describes this properly."
Well, we do. You take Maxwell theory, if
it's still linear, if it's still
superposition, you take Maxwell theory,
but with this Lagrangian.
So, L Maxwell or Lagrangian density is
the square root of minus G. You have the
FAB FCD. So, normally you would use two
metrics to to tie these together to the
F squared action. But now, you just use
GABCD,
this kind of object which gets then
induced symmetries like
square here and there's an exchange
symmetry, whatever.
And this is what explains linear super
birefringence in materials. It would
also explain birefringence I would
encode birefringence in the vacuum.
Okay. So, here you have a theory can
calculate the principal polynomial, blah
blah blah. You you you understand the
drill. So, what one needs to do and
that's actually one of the projects that
Max and other of my students are working
on is to derive the gravity theory that
consistently underlies the assumption
that there could be something like this
in space-time.
And then you have a prediction where the
effect will be strong. If you just point
your telescope somewhere and say, "Oh, I
don't see birefringence." That's not
particularly convincing. You can also
point your telescope somewhere and then
say, "Oh, there is slight bending." You
need to look precisely where it is or
you get yesterday you calculated the
radiation of the binary pulsar. You need
to know what you're looking for in order
to discover that object, right?
Otherwise, it's not a Nobel Prize if
everybody can see it. Right? And so, the
point is you can calculate the gravity
theory underlying. So, even if you don't
wait for dark energy to be somehow put
into equations in a hundred years in
order to carry this through, you can ask
questions many people are asking. But
instead of just parameterizing some
deviation in the standard theory with an
extra term, you have a well-rounded full
theory of the matter and the underlying
gravity.
And it is not Einstein gravity. So, the
question is which matter gives you
different gravity than Einstein gravity?
The answer is whenever the matter has a
principal polynomial that's different
from this one.
Okay? And that is whenever the principal
the cone of the principal polynomial
looks more complicated than the double
light cone.
As simple as that. So, every matter,
however complicated it is, that has this
principal polynomial,
that's standard matter. So, for
instance, one second. For instance, you
know, you have the Dirac algebra, right?
Who's seen the Dirac algebra?
So, they ain't curved space and
something like this. So, there's
something like that. Right?
Why?
Why? Because Dirac told us so. Well,
because
exactly because
if this is the Dirac equation without
mass, say,
you can calculate the principal
polynomial of this. What you guess it
will be?
It's PKK equals G inverse KAKB. It's the
principal polynomial of Maxwell theory.
That is the reason why you need these
guys to be like that.
Dirac matter, standard matter there.
Okay?
Anyway, I I could tell a lot about this,
but you get the picture. Yes.
Does the
degree of the principal polynomial then
also relate to the number of
presentation constants?
No, it's
it's very hard to say. So, the question
you ask is if you go in with a certain
type of matter,
you can classify it according to the
degree of the principal polynomial, to
the rank of the tensor that underlies it
and whatnot.
The answer to your question, how many
degrees of freedom are there in the
gravitational theory,
requires that for that matter you solve
these equations or you find an abstract
way,
the way of existence and uniqueness and
whatever you, huh?
To study these equations without solving
them.
So, for instance, the question, is there
an alternate not alternate, is there a
gravity theory that can underlie
this type of matter whose equations I
put down?
Is there a gravity theory? That's the
question mathematically, the question of
existence of a solution of the system.
Well, is there one or are there many?
Well, that's mathematically the question
of uniqueness of solutions.
And what on earth is the theory
concretely so I can calculate? That's
the question of practically solving the
equations. But all of these are physi-
are mathematical questions. So, we
converted this grand physical question
of what a modified gravity theory could
be
to input from experiment and
observation, matter input,
phenomenological input,
and then we just carry through what
logically is demanded and we convert it
into a purely mathematical problem.
And it is as hard to find such a new
gravity theory as it is to solve these
equations.
But again, so now you could ask could
one do perturbation theory and so on.
These are all stuff. This is all stuff
we're following. Okay? Yes. Uh Dirac
equations describe spin half particles.
Yes. I have not seen a spin half
particle which is massless. So, I'm not
sure if this can work.
Yeah, some problems very easily fixed.
It's still the same principal
polynomial. But are there some It stops
up Why why is it the same principal
polynomial? Because you only need to
look at the highest order term as I
instructed you. But what about spinorial
tensors in these equations?
Um
we don't have them because as I said,
if you start with a smooth manifold as
your bottom line,
every study needs a bottom line. You
start with that as the bottom line. Then
at first, you can only consider
tensors. Once you identified the
principal polynomial with some test
matter,
right? Then you can redo Dirac's
question and you can say, "I want now
also other representations."
But now, it will not be a binary algebra
uh that you need, but you will need a
degree P array algebra. So, it's from mu
to sigma and these guys run both So,
these are degree P many. This is the
principal polynomial. This is the new
Dirac algebra and it's no longer a
problem of binary algebra where you have
two entries. It's a problem with degree
P many entries.
And one can show that. So, that's what
one of my PhD students studied amongst
other things on on these space-times,
how you can establish non-tensorial
matter. That is how it goes. And in the
special case where the polynomial is the
metric, it looks like this. This is why
the indices are up.
Because actually the the polynomial, the
principal polynomial in the Dirac
algebra.
Okay?
Okay. So, you solve these guys. So, the
problem of finding modified gravities
key theories, but modified always sounds
like we we want to modify. We don't want
to modify, but if matter demands it, we
will and that's the way to do it. It's a
mathematical question. We reduce it to a
purely mathematical question.
There are no free parameters in the
theory. It's not of the type you add
some terms and then, "Oh, they're so
highly suppressed, but I still believe
in it." or something.
You get these equations and they are
what they are. You solve them and you
will get parameters because they're
differential equations. You will get
undetermined stuff.
And see how useful that is, right? And
then, the only thing you need to make